[Music]
good morning John it's Friday March 2nd
you guys are all really mean I mean I
love you but you're mean kind of just
like John okay not all of you are me
honor and marine and a couple of you
guys we're out there defending me but
the people have spoken and I await my
punishment one condition please
nothing to do with earwax there's been
talk of us introducing more politics
into Brotherhood 2.0 and this is not
something I think we have a choice about
we're both very politically active and
interested people and not talking about
politics would be lying and there's no
way we're gonna exclude that from our
conversation however I'm with commenter
Miller went on this one it's too early
to endorse anyone honestly I mean we
don't even know if the primary field is
filled out yet what if there's one
candidate behind the scene whose name
and politics and abilities are already
well known enough that he doesn't have
to announce early someone who's maybe
waiting for the other primary candidates
to finish ripping each other to shreds
before he announces someone who hasn't
been able to come up with a firm answer
the question will you run for president
for the last year and a half I think we
should wait and see plus Dennis Kucinich
his wife is hot Daniel Biss once said
that she's the one and only success the
Democratic Party had in 2004 I could
totally do that as the first lady
finally I wanted to share with you a few
juicy bits of knowledge first commenter
scott says that he would like my
punishment to be long and lasting and
painful i think i might hate comment er
Scott but I would like to take this
opportunity to announce that I have been
living with ulcerative colitis what does
that mean well if you're wondering what
it's like this advertisement I think
sums it up fairly well hidden fire the
great butt explosion ii lose s says that
myriad is one of her favorite words and
i wanted her to know that it comes from
the greek Miriah DOS meaning 10,000 and
that I didn't get you a wedding present
either so apparently I look like people
first you say I look like this guy
then you say look like this guy then you
say it look like this girl
I mean Heath Ledger was in that movie
maybe yesterday get that haircut okay
this is extremely strange I just wanted
to say I'm being John for a day I'm
being John for a day I live in New York
and buy expensive jeans I'm loved and
adored by half dozens of teens oh I'm
being John for a day and I'll see you
tomorrow
Oh on Monday I'll see you on Monday